In this video we will understand what
angles are and how they are measured the
concept of angles is very simple to know what an angle is we just need to know what a
ray means look at this
point if I draw a
line which starts off from a  point and goes
indefinitely in one direction it is called a
ray this is one ray and if we have another ray like this then what we have between
m is called an angle note that the two rays
originate from a single point so an angle
can be defined  As Some Measure Between Two Raises What Are These Two Raises Called These Two Raises Are Called
The Arms Of The Angle This Arm Where The Angle
Starts Is Called The Initial Arm And This Arm Where
The Angle Ends Is Called
The Terminal Arm Both
The Arms Of The  Angle Meet at One
Point This point is called the vertex
to raise Meet at one point to form an angle and we also
refer to it as the origin Both the raises originate from this
point Where do we see angles in everyday life
The best example is wood  Be that of a clock
an angle is formed between the minute hand and the
hour hand
and may be this house which has a ladder
leaning on it there is an angle formed by the
ladder with the ground and look at this picture there
is an angle formed  Here Between Her
Hands And This Star Who Has Angles Inside
As Well As Outside But How Do We Measure It
Is It Always Positive What Notation Do We Use We See
All That In The Coming
[Music]
Videos